thank you thank you thank you good
morning please sit this is obviously an
extremely special day usually I get to
be the guest or the guest of honor for
these things but to be a host is a
different dynamic and I just want to
first and foremost thank Kim and Emma
and Russ and the rest of the Vayner
experience team for putting this
together what's what's really
interesting about this event is many
different things number one the fact
that it is being held at the home of a
team that I hate with all my heart
number two I think it would be
imperative for me to thank Steve Ross
the owner of dolphins and Matt Higgins
the CEO there is no way we're doing this
event here if they're not our partners
so I think we should clap that up
because this is gorgeous
I also want to thank all the speakers
that came out to present the content we
have incredible content throughout and
obviously I'm looking forward to my next
session with Ryan obviously real estate
has a tremendous path here but travel
auto insurance the the the whole thing
is super interesting to me and I'm
excited you know when I when I came up
with the concept of the name I thought
it was interesting to create a
conference that actually expires we our
ambition is to create this brand agent
2021 for people that we have as agents
you know obviously we picked the four
sectors industries that I think what I'm
about to keynote about really matter the
timing around my new book crushing it
and and this talk is very important
because what is stunning to me is how
much opportunity there is for everybody
at this conference and and what it means
at this moment and to me as you guys
hear a lot I day trade attention I try
not to guess I don't predict and for me
there's a very clear path of how the
next 36 to 48 months play out and so I'm
excited about doing this for the next
four years I think Kim and I were
talking we're like you know as well as
this goes we're probably not gonna
that of room here and so I think we're
pretty focused on doing it here for the
next four years and and I really hope
that it's cool and we're excited to
build on this so knowing that quite a
few of you have a lot of context for me
and my content I was giving a lot of
thought to what I wanted to talk about
this morning and I kind of thought of it
as less of a presentation or a keynote
and less as a Q&A session because we
didn't set it up that format and more of
kind of just like you know and a lot of
you know this there's a and you probably
live it as well you're always gonna talk
a little bit different to 800 people
then you're gonna talk to one person at
a time and there's always different
gears a lot of times I talk about having
empathy for people not loving me at
first because if they see me in an
interview or on a keynote stage that's a
different version because I've got to
communicate in a different style the
context is different what I thought
would be super interesting this morning
with this talk was give this talk in the
manner that it's really legitimately
just like one on one and the and instead
of two 800 because what I think is
unique about the way we set this up is I
really do believe the advice I'm about
to give the thoughts that I want you to
debate are an extremely one-on-one and
literally map across the board so why we
sector these groups together more
importantly this is not an audience that
is in the dugout right this is you know
the far majority of you are much further
along than debating if social media or
the Internet is a good idea or that
you're running you know print ads and
bus stop ads instead of other things so
a lot of things were going through my
mind last night early this morning and I
think the thing that I really want to
focus on right off the bat actually real
quick because I see a lot of people
standing can you raise your hand if you
have a seat next to you open just to let
if anybody in the back wants to try to
grab a seat can you guys hold it up for
a second because I just want to give
everybody a chance in the back to sit
down what I think is super important to
really attack
this morning is even though I know that
this is a 201 or 301 curriculum crowd I
truly believe that most of you don't
understand how big the stakes are
because you get caught the way I get
caught I think one of the biggest
mistakes that I've made in my career is
I've been so on the cusp of things you
know very early on too early then I kind
of hit my prime in the early mid 2000s
where I was getting my timing down this
is why I talk about day trading
attention this will not be about virtual
reality today even though I know in 16
years VR may affect your business I
think what I've done well is I'm
practical this is not about guessing
this is not about trying to be ahead of
the curve or position myself as the vine
to guy because it's new I'm trying to
really understand what is happening
right this second that makes you know a
home sell you know what makes a sneaker
sell you know what what what is going on
right now and so what happens when you
understand that and when you're early
and you get the benefits of it
especially if you're getting the
benefits of it how many people here by
show of hands and please raise your hand
if it's true feel like their digital
marketing forget about social feel like
their digital marketing is going well
and is impacting their business in a
positive way raise your hands that's
what I'm actually weirdly worried about
that was more than half the audience and
here's where I'm excited I don't believe
that most of us understand how early it
is and I'm worried that you haven't gone
deep enough while you're thinking about
going wider from a pure practical sense
I feel like a lot of people are debating
their podcast or their Facebook watch
video shows or their vlog or an Alexis
scale because you're paying attention to
what I'm putting out for free on a daily
basis you're doing well on Facebook ads
or Google ads but you're leaving so much
more on
table I know this because even I'm doing
that like I know for a fact that I
should be running this this would be ROI
positive for my life I should probably
be running somewhere in the ballpark of
a hundred to two hundred thousand
dollars a month in Instagram ads and I'm
spending ten so just think about the
Delta like you know this is a
conversation I had yesterday with Andy
I'm like [ __ ] man these Instagram ads
are so [ __ ] cheap right my content is
doing so well on that platform how many
people here are pretty into Instagram
right now raise your hands weird
everyone and yet I'm not fully squeezing
it and so I think the vulnerability for
a 301 a 201 executors of what's going on
is the fact that we aren't fully going
deep enough and so what I would
challenge everybody to think about this
morning more than anything is a couple
things number one the facebook arbitrage
of its cost is stunningly underpriced if
I could give you the biggest piece of
advice that would be blanket that I know
everybody could be affected by whether
you have a restaurant or did whether you
have a liquor store or did whether
you're in the real estate business
insurance I know for a fact for fact
that you could Ford 50 times X your
investment in both creative the pictures
the videos the written words and in
actually spending the ads to get far
more the fact that you're spending and
it's working is hiding the fact that
there's a lot more underneath that and I
would really really really take
advantage of this morning to set up to
set up the mindset for you to realize
there's probably a lot more going on in
the depth than there is in the width
before you get inspired to start your
show your podcast your Lexus skill
what's going on with vine to when it
comes out before do you do that which he
should but I feel like for most of us
including myself that should be 20% of
our energy and mind and eighty percent
should be looking very carefully at
what's working and getting far more
committed to it because when I look back
at Google for me and again I know I'm
making too many assumptions this morning
that most people know who I am
Wine Library was built on Google and
email right like the narrative you know
over time gets manipulated it's like
social media Wine Library was built on
Google and email I was built on social
media Wine Library TV was built on
social media which had a great impact
but when there was no money and there
was very little marketing dollars and
that's the case for so many no matter
where you are whether you're holding
back the money cuz you want to buy [ __ ]
instead of reinvesting in your business
or because your business is still small
and you don't have the money the way to
go from somewhere to a totally different
level is actually very intriguing it's
based on being right it's based on being
very smart it's based on you're spending
a lot of people here compete with each
other theoretically just for attention
forget about being in the you know I
think one thing that our Budweiser
client taught me in a meeting a couple
years ago for vaynermedia blew my mind
I'm in it it's early I don't know their
business very well and I'm talking about
competing with Heineken and Coors Light
and they looked at me like Oh child
they're like we don't compete with that
we compare for share of throat we're not
competing with Heineken we're comparing
we're competing for everybody's share of
throat they're worried about bottled
water they're worried about sprite
they're worried about coconut water the
word about [ __ ] oxygen and so I think
one thing that I want to make sure
everybody understands here you know
being in the businesses that you are you
naturally have some great
competitiveness but when you meet
somebody here today and they're from
Guatemala like I met the lovely guy from
this morning and you're from Cincinnati
doesn't feel like you're really
competing with each other because you're
not selling homes or products or trying
to get their travel business to the same
market I think you are competing because
to get attention is one feed
it's a supply of attention and so for me
what I wanted to establish this morning
knowing that there was a ridiculous
lineup of other speakers knowing that a
lot of the speakers we strategically
picked are gonna go into more details I
wanted to really go into the nuances of
the mindset that I think it will help to
take people to the next level look
here's something else that's super
interesting to me we are living through
an incredibly interesting time right now
where because of the state of our
country because in the political realm
and in the parenting realm we are now in
full mode of demonizing technology if
you go read the headlines that the
masses are reading we are demonizing
technology Facebook and Twitter are
jeopardizing our democracy kids are
spending too much time on these iPads
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah this
is an incredible opportunity this is
making me very happy I am hoping that
the mainstream media and social media
continues to [ __ ] on technology because
what that's gonna mean is people are
gonna back off of it they're gonna get
confused about that and it's gonna leave
me more time to grab tool and supply
that I'm looking for I prefer when
people are going down paths that are the
conventional wisdom that I don't agree
with I love when all of you hit me up on
Twitter when somebody says something
like Facebook sucks and you guys retweet
me and you're like Gary Vee what do you
think cuz you want me to come in and
punch him in the [ __ ] face and when I
see that tweet in my stream I smile cuz
I'm like yes Facebook sucks and so I
think there's a really incredible theme
that I'm trying to create in these first
ten minutes which is the following for
the fact that I've been ranting about
this stuff for a decade and this is by
the way why I'm real crushing it I never
ever ever thought I would write a
follow-up to that book because I thought
in 2008 and then it came out no nine
that in a decade it would be
conventional wisdom
that people could make money on YouTube
and into him how many people read
crushing around the time it came out
raise your hands
awesome so for a lot of you you remember
it was a little bit out there it was
like if you go read the first three four
hundred reviews of crush it on Amazon a
lot of its like this is straight
[ __ ] nobody's ever gonna make a
hundred thousand dollars on YouTube like
it was like completely crazy talk and
literally like and just for the
youngsters in here or people that kind
of came along the way you know later on
and now this is all accepted it would be
like me standing here right now and
saying things like you're gonna make
you're gonna sell virtual homes on VR
and you're gonna make fourteen million
dollars a year selling virtual homes
that don't exist right like and and most
people just won't believe that like you
could guess and you'd be like cool maybe
and this and that but don't forget we
also didn't have the last decade of
technology advances when I talked about
that people hadn't accepted the energy
there were still people not really into
the Internet in two thousand eight and
nine and so what strikes me this morning
is a very simple fact for everything
that has happened for all the obvious
nests for the kid you know I know I know
20 year olds that are making forty to
seventy million dollars a year on the
back of their Instagram and YouTube and
selling merchandise
this is these numbers have become
staggering like just so you guys know in
the next 36 months next four years it
will become obvious to America and the
world that celebrities on social media
are making dramatically more money than
celebrities in real life when you guys
read the headline that to kids that do
soccer tricks are making on YouTube and
Facebook and Instagram in five years are
making more money than Ronaldo shit's
gonna get confusing and this is what's
happening and so I guess the energy that
I really want to bring this morning very
simply in this calm demeanor is it
hasn't even started
and I think a lot of us think it's in it
that were in it that it's been happening
that a lot of good stuff has happened
for others for ourselves literally if
you're in this audience and have done
nothing
you have 401 followers on Twitter your
Facebook page is still your personal
page and you don't have a fan page
you've done nothing on the incident
literally if you're at nothing which is
by the way extremely rare for this
audience but common for most of mine I
actually think that the audience I spoke
to yesterday in New Orleans who were
construction and general contractors who
are not in this at all have a weird
slight advantage over a lot of people in
here which is why I using this as my
opening rant they have heard about all
this stuff but haven't started and so
for them it's a clean slate and they're
just going in
you've already been affected positively
or negatively you've already had
successes and failures
you've already quantified this yet I
don't believe that we've quantified how
big it actually is so this whole little
rant is very simple here's where I'm at
with all of you number one you need to
realize how [ __ ] great it is to be
alive and a professional during this
time right now because it was worse for
your grandparents and it's gonna be
worse for your grandkids here's why this
moment right now this is how it's going
to play out and I'm putting it on film
and I'll look back at it this is the
land grab of the Internet
virtual reality will come and maybe
you'll learn from this and so many of
you are young and in 20 years everybody
in this audience will be able to land
grab their virtual reality space but
right now this is the land grab to
establish yourself as the personality
the authority the organization the
service in your industry still you could
have four competitors who've got more
followers than you you can have people
you look up to that have crushed it and
things of that nature that will speak
today but still we haven't even come
close the analogy I would use is if if I
am part of the crew that bought
beachfront property in Malibu for the
attention of the end consumer on the
internet worst
selling the second row of homes and a
lot of people here think we're already
not even selling that neighborhood
cuz it's sold out do you understand what
I really really really want to get
across this morning is that the
opportunity hasn't even fully begun the
penetration of attention hasn't begun
the biggest companies in the world have
still not been spending on Facebook dice
you have to understand that over the
next three to five years and I don't
know when but somewhere in that window
eventually coca-cola and BMW and
Budweiser are gonna wake up and they're
not gonna spend seventy and eighty
percent of their money on television
commercials and banner ads and that's
what's happening just so you know when
they do and they are on the cusp because
when things like Toys R Us go out of
business people get scared and I don't
know if you guys saw the Netflix numbers
that came out yesterday like Netflix is
about the past cable television before
you know it it's not gonna take them
very long like shit's happened and so in
the next 36 months when you're trying to
put your content or your open house or
where I should travel to on a Facebook
feed and today it costs four to six to
seven dollars to get in front of a
thousand people speed of only which 25
we'll look at it because you know how
you go through the feed which is fine if
that cost six to seven dollars today
when the biggest companies in the world
get serious about this in the next three
to four years it's gonna cost you 40 and
that's gonna [ __ ] up your business
that's gonna make the ROI not as good
simple supply and demand I play no other
game supply and demand of your attention
period end of story so what does this
all mean here's how I think this plays
out I genuinely believe that eighty
percent and that includes people that
are more shy and scared to be on camera
and are introverted I believe that
eighty percent of this audience over the
next half decade is gonna start debating
having a d-roc and an iris and a babban
I think all of you over the next decade
will realize that you are in the media
biz
that before that you are any kind of
agent you are actually a show that the
[ __ ] that you watch on Bravo and HGTV
and all the other [ __ ] channels you
could do the same thing outside of the
guy we have here in his show and about
three other shows nobody really watches
any of these cable shows like an average
social media youtube executor is getting
a bigger audience than a lot of these
shows on the fifteenth channel you've
never heard of show version of you and
yet you're in the industry and you look
at them be like oh they're so lucky
they're not lucky they have no control
of the post edit they have no control of
the marketing and nobody knows they're
on channel 447 on [ __ ] DirecTV you're
lucky that you haven't signed a deal
with any of those kind of things and the
fact that you can take your phone and
put on Facebook and YouTube literally
the biggest thing that's holding back
the far majority of this room from going
to a completely different level
financially and happy wise is the fact
that every year they're just taking home
too much of the money they made and
they're buying cars and vacations and
homes and [ __ ] [ __ ] jewelry if
you actually took half the money that
you took home last year whatever you did
think about your business think about
you took right which for a lot of people
here is what you made if you took half
of that and you put that into Facebook
and Instagram ads and to people helping
you make content full-time you would
make three times the money you're gonna
make this year and in one year you would
have returned back the investment we
have to thanks we have to we have to and
you guys can tell I'm not coming with
the normal like yeah I'm coming with a
very like listen to me [ __ ] I'm I'm
putting a slag in the ground here today
this morning to make it very clear which
is I didn't write this new book this is
not what I'm gonna speak about for the
next year for kicks and giggles I'm
selfish to be historically correct
everything I the reason you guys like me
is I only put out content in one filter
will I be right when somebody watch
this video in four years period that's
it no other ROI no top of the funnel to
the course no one thing
will I be right so I'm always making
content that's selfish for the audience
which is why it's good for you listen to
me listen to me good if you are not
fully committed to spending as much
money and time on building your personal
brand which means upping your content on
these five to seven channels by a
magnitude of fifty to five thousand
times more content you are making a huge
mistake you're making a fundamental miss
that you will regret tremendously when
you look back at this day in four years
and what's interesting is normally and
you guys watch my stuff this is where I
say I'm only hoping for two or three of
you to actually do this what's emotional
for me and probably why we decided to do
this conference is I think [ __ ]
twenty percent of you are gonna do this
because a lot of you have already
flirted you know it's a lot easier to
kind of jump off you know a building in
a parachute when you've done it off a
twenty foot cliff you guys already on
your way I just think that in that the
fact that you're on your way that you've
started that you give a [ __ ] is actually
potentially the reason you can't get to
the next place it's good enough you're
checking the box you are doing it so
many of you are like I am doing social
media but nothing good has come of it
and to me this is the moment and
especially look I like taking advantage
of when times are good how many people
here have been in their industry for
over 20 years
raise your hand raise it high you want
to get a sense okay so here's what you
guys know that people how many people
have been in their industry for less
than nine years raise your hand perfect
so this is even better than I thought
there's a small percentage here who are
over 20 the far majority is under 9 what
the under nines don't know is a bad
economy doing this maybe they're doing
something new and so I saw the hands and
some of them were doing other things and
I asked in this profession so maybe they
do know how many people have only been a
professional for less than 10 years
raise your hand
so this is what I'm scared of you're
soft you're not soft because you're soft
you're soft because the market has been
soft since you've been a professional
you didn't get punched in the [ __ ]
mouth in 2008 you didn't [ __ ] melt in
2000 and 2001 you didn't get completely
annihilated in the mid-90s you think
you're special and you don't just
realize that it's a simple game right
now
there's so much [ __ ] money in the
system that there's a ton of [ __ ] C
and D players in here who think they're
a z' cuz it's [ __ ] easy that's the
truth
and so and I think most of you know me
I'm not sitting up here on my high horse
saying I'm good and you suck I'm saying
please for the love of God understand
why people get [ __ ] flamed out during
crashes and other people don't and they
hang on and then make a ton more money
on the backend because 80% of people get
flamed out and things are a quarter on
the dollar the reason they do is they do
two core things at all times the reason
I leave tens of millions of dollars on
the table every year is because I don't
do the behaviors to put myself
vulnerable into the world melting
tomorrow because I know that college
debt is gonna tear down the American
economy the way that all the [ __ ]
ratings of lending did in the housing
crisis I know that there's an obnoxious
amount of 26 to 35 year olds and and
Ryan who I'm gonna fireside chat told me
this over breakfast I did a bunch of
homework yesterday
it's 100% gonna happen literally college
debt is gonna tear down our economy
cuz all these kids are getting money
still lent to them and they have no
prayer of never paying back to college
debt let alone the the money that
they're borrowing to buy a [ __ ] house
and you guys in real estate all know
it's true just happening all over again
and so shit's pretty basic my friends
you can't rip [ __ ] in the short term
negativity wins the short game reality
and merit and positivity win the long
game shit's gonna hit the fan and too
many people here are taking their riches
in this easy time
they're buying dumb [ __ ] instead of
saving and investing if you go from
making a million to making 13 during
this era going from 13 to 4 is different
than going from a million to working a
Chase Bank and so I heed this morning in
this beautiful town on this awesome day
I'm not rolling with negativity and be
careful I'm rolling with let's be
[ __ ] practical let's be practical not
on defense this isn't hoard your money
and wait for the world and go into the
bunk this is if you're making money
right now
please reinvest it in the one thing that
doesn't get shattered during a bad
economy which is your reputation I love
when people get mad about the word
personal brand because they think it's
douchey it's just a semantics of a word
your personal brand is your reputation
it always mattered it's how we always
made money it's how so many of you that
have been successful for 20 years have
been able to be successful except you
didn't have technology to put it on
steroids
it was just word of mouth now one shared
tweet do you know how many of you were
taking photos of this putting it on your
social and then your friends at home see
this and that's why there's gonna be
three thousand people here next year
word of mouth on steroids the Internet
and social media specifically is just
one thing its plumbing its plumbing to
make your words and thoughts go further
than they did in 1974 when a couple of
yentas did it for us
word of mouth on steroids and so what I
want you to do is I want you to create
content that can be accelerated through
word of mouth and I'm fascinated by how
many of you aren't even remotely close
to producing the max amount of content I
know this because I only give advice
that I took myself you guys how many
people have been following me for over
five years raise your hand then you guys
know I have accelerated my content
dramatically over the last 18 months I
host Oracle II only sit here and talk
about things that I've already done
because I don't like standing up here
and guessing and giving
vice and hoping it works out because
that's how people lose I only talk about
what I've already lived my book right
now which comes out in six days
pre-order right now or I'll cry is thank
you is selling literally last night I
called Colin where I was on a livestream
hit me up I has a lot of you know
usually around this time have buy 25
books and come over and take a selfie
buy a hundred books and I'll buy you a
milkshake buy a thousand books and I'll
sleep over your [ __ ] house like I I
normally am in ridiculous sales mode
right now for any of you that have been
along for this ride over the last five
years the whole Jab Jab Jab right hook
this is normally my right hook time yes
I'm talking about it but there is
nothing close to what Jab Jab Jab right
hook and askgaryvee looks like right now
because my branding because of my
content for the last 18 months is doing
all the selling for me I don't know how
many people saw my Instagram live last
night when I was raised your hands
obstinacy so you guys saw yesterday a
good friend of mine Daymond John from
Shark Tank had his book come out right
he [ __ ] was on Wendy Williams dr. oz
Harry [ __ ] Connick jr. Yahoo [ __ ]
finance face book that Jewish did
something with him he went bonkers I
looked at his Amazon rank he was 17 my
book was 19 I'm a week away doing
nothing for it and it just hit me so
hard I'm like this is just so black and
white this is so black and white I know
that if I can suffocate all of you today
to take 25% of your take-home income
this year and pour it back into two
people who do video and written word and
put it into Facebook and Instagram ads
literally all of you will email me 24
months actually [ __ ] it if you can start
right away
literally 25% of you are going to come
to me this time next year right here and
be like holy [ __ ] I've been listening to
your stuff for seven years your keynote
was different in Miami last year at this
time I listened I said [ __ ] it I don't
need to go to Ibiza three times this
year [ __ ] it I don't need to buy a
better
BMW this year to make me feel good with
the neighbors [ __ ] it I don't need
another [ __ ] pair of Supremes or
Yeezys I took the money and I put it
into Karen the film woman and Rick the
ad guy and now my business is 2x this
will 100% work even if you suck [ __ ] on
camera have zero charisma our only eight
days in the industry this will work
because it is such under priced
attention that the ROI will work that if
you're a 2n skill the ads are a twenty
in the ten point scale and it closes the
Delta of you being average if you
literally literally and I've said this
for seven years if you literally
literally go interview the guy who owns
the gym in town the guy who owns the
pizza shop the woman that owns the
insurance brokerage if you literally
literally literally just interview your
local community that you become the
local newspaper in three minute video
form on your phone you don't even need
to [ __ ] hire d-roc or babban drives
your [ __ ] phone if you literally take
it selfie it and interview the principal
of the school in your neighborhood you
will become the local celebrity who can
then transact on whatever you're trying
to sell that group if you bring value to
people if you interview the best high
school basketball player literally just
that your business will change or if you
literally just give the advice of how
you got here what you learned if you
shared your thoughts if you do not
understand that you were a media company
that you will not be as successful as
you are today in a decade and that's not
interesting when the alternative is
you're four to seven times bigger this
think guys you have to understand what
happened to Blockbuster and Netflix what
happened with uber and taxi companies
what happened with shitty hotels versus
Airbnb is happening with you as a human
in your business and so when you have
the best hand and you know it because
you've been paying attention and you
know how to play poker
you go all-in everybody here is playing
Facebook Instagram social media YouTube
podcasting like they have the best hand
and they're calling and you're not going
them into getting all the money you're
just [ __ ] folding and that's this
audience so can you imagine what I feel
is going on outside this stadium so this
is a call to action for everybody to do
me one favor and I do think I can get a
lot of you to do it which excites the
[ __ ] out of me
please right now listen maybe you've
laid out money maybe you're in the
middle of a renovation maybe you're
paying for your kids college
Mazel Tov I know there's nuances on
everybody's life but if you are in a
position where literally your take-home
income this year is literally the stuff
you're gonna go and do things with
please from 25% to 90% if you can go
humble please take that money and hire
two people to make a lot more content
for you about you and your business and
please give the rest of the money to
Facebook and YouTube and Instagram and I
fundamentally promise you you will walk
here to this conference next year and
personally thank me emotionally because
your business will change and I know not
one of you has gone all-in for all the
Carlos and Sebastian and a bunch of
personalities here for Mitch like I'm
watching what you guys are doing I'm
consuming the [ __ ] out of you oh by the
way the reason I don't watch anything I
love when I you're welcome you know
you're welcome you know how people get
this is the time on social media when
people get mad at me and say [ __ ] like
oh this [ __ ] guy he doesn't read any
books but he wants you to buy his book I
don't I want you to do whatever [ __ ] you
want to do I don't need you to come to
this I don't need you to give me one
second of your time I want you to do
what you want to do I don't read books
because I spend my life watching what
you do so that I can get smarter because
that's how it gets me to the front line
understanding what humans are doing and
about to do is how I make my living it's
what makes me talented I'm able to
synthesize your behaviors I have told
you over the last decade things that you
were gonna do
that you told me in your head that you
wouldn't do that you now do so this is
what I do and what I'm telling you right
now is very very very serious I believe
that every single person at this
conference even though there are 201 301
or 401 in advancements are not going
anywhere close to enough because I think
I'm the best of the bunch and I just
told you I'm spending one tenth of the
amount of AD money that I should be
spending on Instagram I will I'm sitting
up here being selfish I'm just trying to
convince myself to drop a [ __ ] hundred
racks on [ __ ] Instagram I'm just
listening to be convincing myself to
[ __ ] and do the right thing my friends
this is the greatest era to be an
entrepreneur in the history of the human
race the infrastructure costs are zero
listening to people complain about
Facebook algorithm changes when Facebook
is free if you decide in an algorithm if
you run ads you don't give a [ __ ] about
the algorithm change I don't give a [ __ ]
about the algorithm change I think the
ads are worth $60 and I pay for that's a
good deal could you imagine paying 15 X
less for something than you feel it's
worth so I don't care about that we're
gonna change but if you do cuz you got a
nice little organic thing going I just
want to remind you something it's free
you're complaining about something that
is free that has helped you sell [ __ ]
let's just quietly one more time because
I need everybody to actually [ __ ]
understand what I'm saying
it's free I literally have emails this
is like real life guys I get emails
saying [ __ ] Gary Vee I knew it you
told me to go all-in on Facebook did you
see the headline sucks like [ __ ]
sucks sucks changed the algorithm [ __ ]
my first reply if I even have the
patience to reply to something like that
is what else are you spending
advertising on well I'm running some
Google AdWords I'm doing some print I'm
doing it I'm like how's that working not
that great I'm like you're mad at
something that's free that's changing
but you're not mad at something you're
spending money for that's giving you
dick in return my
there is massive confusion in the system
I literally had a meeting with a top
executive in corporate world who spent
the first 30 minutes of our meeting
yelling at me that Facebook and social
media was destroying our democracy that
it was that powerful right and then the
30 minutes after was him fighting me
from moving some money from television
to Facebook because he thought it didn't
work so I said to him after the hour I
said cool cuz I try no I don't sell
people who are buying I'm just leaving
my two cents on the record I think one
of the great things that a lot of you
because there's a lot of salespeople in
here I have to understand you can't sell
the unsellable the amount of time you
waste trying to convince somebody to buy
versus finding the next person to buy is
extraordinary waste but after I spoke to
him I said you spent the first 30
minutes telling me that these were such
powerful communication tools that it was
literally shaking the foundation of our
300-year democracy and then you spent
the second half of the 30 minutes
telling me that that same machine was
not capable of selling makeup there is
ridiculous confusion in the system I am
winning and will win at all time levels
get ready you will tell your grandkids
that you once saw me live like I mean
that and by the way it's not because by
the way I don't by the way real quick
cuz I don't want claps for that I need
you to understand how I think about that
it's not because I think I'm fancy or
great I think it's because I'm very
common simple about one simple tiny
thing underpriced the tension it's so
grossly underpriced I'm asking you let
me tell you the story about MTV when MTV
came out in the early to mid 80s how
many people remember when MTV was
launched when empty when MTV was
launched the biggest bands in the world
the biggest bands in the world got
together for a dinner that one of their
managers told me about and decided that
they would not make music videos for MTV
because that was giving away music for
free
that why would we spend money to make a
video put it on MTV but when that's
giving people the music for free and
they will not go out and buy the record
at the same token up-and-coming artists
Madonna Duran Duran and on and on
understood that it was where all the
attention of the youth was and it was a
gateway drug to the sale they understood
that MTV was a jab not the right hook
Facebook and Instagram at this second is
the most underpriced scaled jab in the
history of marketing except for one
other moment from 2001 to 2005 Google
AdWords was a ridiculously under priced
jab how many people here took advantage
of Google 2001 to 2005 raise your hands
so for you you really know that's how I
did it
Wine Library had no money but when
you're buying people who want to buy
wine for five and ten cents a click it
works out real fast when it's that
underpriced one company one company
during that time acted the way I'm
aspiring to act right now as Gary
Vaynerchuk on social media one company
from 2001 to 2005 spent enough to
justify how underpriced it was that
company was a small book company called
Amazon Amazon as you all know now is the
company of our world it will win
everything it hasn't even begun
literally the only thing that will stop
Amazon is antitrust government
involvement otherwise it will [ __ ]
destroy everything
it got its fuel from Google 2001 to 2005
that occurrence is happening right now
on Facebook and Instagram and we're not
squeezing the juice out of that fruit
anywhere close at least we have picked
up the fruit some of you are kind of
squeezing the fruit I'm kind of
squeezing the fruit harder this group
going forward
and so what that's exactly the I blurt
that I blow out the speakers that be a
music not dinner I was really hoping I
blew out the speakers to be very honest
with you I think it would went super
[ __ ] viral I went for that for impact
because I really need to penetrate this
morning's talk with the demeanor and
lack of normal over-the-top energy I'm
trying to go in a very one-on-one thing
here my friends a lot of you I've known
for a long time a lot of you I've paid
attention to subtly for a long time if
I'm not a hundred percent and I'm at 50
you're at [ __ ] two four and seven
there's so much for you to grab please
let this little slider of an energy talk
that I gave this morning be the
off-speed pitch to get you really
thinking about how ridiculous this is
please let the energy of this talk set
up the rest of the day so that you pay
even closer attention so that you even
though you're doing well have the
humility today to raise your hand or to
ask somebody a question because you want
a front that you know but what you don't
know is where all the [ __ ] magic is
please understand that when you
videotape your day or meetings that that
content works three ways if you
understand it's your YouTube and
Facebook but also the audio can be
stripped how many of you listen to my
podcast razinin
I have a top 50 podcast in the world and
I never sit down and do a podcast I
strip audio from the video of my day two
days do you understand how efficient
this is my LinkedIn is one of the top
red Lincoln's in the world and it's just
as transcribed words of the audio from
my day to day the efficiency of
recording your day and it transcribing
into the three pillars of how people
consume content the written word audio
and video you cover all the ways that
people consume from just videotaping
they please get over the audacity or the
narcissistic nature of having somebody
film you were you filming yourself I
understand I am very comfortable in my
own skin
it was hard for me two years ago to say
I'm gonna have a man follow me around
with a camera it felt like literally the
douchiest thing that I've ever come up
with but it's been the biggest impact of
my career and it hasn't even started and
I know that it can change yours and some
of you are a little bit more talented
and creative and you're a little bit
more of a KC nice tat and you can do it
yourself even better it keeps your costs
down you're in full control most of you
are busy I'm busy I'm running a 200
[ __ ] million dollar company I can't
be vlogging I just need somebody
recording and as you guys know 80% of
the stuff I'm doing day-to-day even
though it seems like I'm filming
everything is not being shown
you're in control I'm not showing you me
firing somebody or negotiating their
salary I'm not as you guys know I'm the
extreme of not showing my family at all
like we are in unprecedented times we
are an unprecedented times and this
group is smart enough to be here at this
Stadium on this day you are different
you need to understand how different you
are in your strategies and your mindset
and how you see it I just need to get
you from the connection of how you see
it
to getting you to commit financially and
mentally and work ethic wise to get you
to get the value the part that's hardest
is sitting here today
you do understand strategies the hardest
part the hardest part is being smart
enough to be here today
the easier part is to make the financial
and work ethic execution part against
the strategies but that's where it's
breaking for most people and so I
implore you to take this day very
seriously
I implore you to do the most ROI
positive thing which is the biggest ROI
of this event is not to take a selfie
with me though I'm ready to take one so
don't be scared it is to fundamentally
meet as many of the 800 other people
here as possible because in those
relationships will come the magic so the
most introverted of you which this
doesn't index massively introverted but
for the most shy or what have you please
challenge yourself to say hello for the
most extroverted don't be a dick and
give
800 [ __ ] business cards tone it down
a hair but but understand what these
next 12 hours or so are this is how do
you make the connection point from the
strategy that you see to getting into
the actual execution starting tonight
starting tomorrow and to how do you
understand that people are the real ROI
in this in technology world and how do
you make three to seven to 14 meaningful
relationships in the next 12 hours I
can't thank you enough for being here I
am so excited about agent 2021 I'm so
humbled that you guys are here I adore
you and I'm really looking forward to
seeing you guys throughout the rest of
the day thank you thank you
I'm excited
[Music]